when people talk about players being
able to score from all three levels this
is it Curry on the mid-range
Curry from three
another mid-range and we've seen his
drives all the way to the whim
this guy is getting it done on another
night second straight game that Curry
has struggled from the three-point line
but it's just been outstanding in every
other area we've got Stephen Curry with
the headset on Steph uh thanks a lot for
taking a few minutes so we were talking
before the game saying look that
Sacramento game seven elimination game
you went off for 50. what were you gonna
have to do tonight where you're gonna
have to have another night like that but
then you get Wiggins going big you got
Draymond going big what can you say
about what they were able to do tonight
they were they were awesome I mean all
the way up and down the roster
um there were contributions Draymond
when he's aggressive especially the way
that they're defending our perimeter
guys uh it gives us a whole nother
element uh him putting pressure on the
rim and we can pull A.D away from the
rim and uh you know just give them a
different look so we love aggressive
wigs and he was that all playoff run
last year and he showed the signs of it
and tonight was the wigs that we want to
see every night so you know like we said
we're coming into this game we just
wanted to win one
give ourselves a chance uh knowing that
we have a big game six down in L.A and
and uh and we obviously need that one
stay low I would like to hear your
thought process on this game five is out
the way game six do you talk about
winning game six and get back to game
seven or do you just focus on game six
no just game six and thinking about what
happened in you know game three and four
down there there was a lot of good that
we could we could take away from those
games playing on the road it's just the
the mentality of you know taking hold of
momentum and not giving them any life
there was a moment in the second quarter
of game three and then the first
three four minutes of game four of the
fourth quarter where we just let go of
the Rope a little bit and gave them life
and they took advantage of it so if we
can get out to a good start
um and then take care of those margin
plays you know a couple turnovers
offensive rebounds whatever it is I
think we'll be in great shape and give
ourselves a chance to uh to come out
with a win on the road
you know when you're in the elimination
game it's obviously totally different
when you're planning a homing on the
road you guys gonna have to really come
out you don't have to have a
conversation about it the first quarter
to keep the crowd out the game is going
to be really important going back to LA
no doubt I think it's just a matter of
uh again just taking stock of what
happened in game three and four
um and honestly I think you know the
pressures on them to protect their home
court we had we had pressure tonight to
again keep ourselves alive with our back
against the wall and and now it shifts
so
um you know I think we can play better
like obviously I haven't shot the ball
well from three you know Clay's uh kind
of Hit or Miss so I feel like we could
take another step and you know give
ourselves a great opportunity that's the
beauty of the playoffs it's every game
is kind of a narrative of its own and
that's what you love about it
you know congratulations First Step but
also you know you look at a game six
there's certain things that you did well
and actually in game four and game five
but what would be the concerns that you
have to stop for the Lakers momentum to
not have a a big night
free throws uh unnecessary fouling
letting the game stop giving them easy
points at the line and then they get to
set their defense
um and then just intention on offense
for us when we have good space in and
we're organized we go at the right
matchups we try to get the right looks
good things happen for us and we're a
little chaotic and and unorganized
um it looks really bad so I think those
two things are the are the focus and and
hopefully those are things that we can
control you can't control makes and
misses it's hard to put that ball in the
basket but those things we can control
and give ourselves a great chance
the Champs are still alive Steph Curry
with 27 and he makes it look softer for
this
good luck in game six we'll talk at you
later appreciate it appreciate you okay
all right this Steph Curry's saying it's
hard to put the ball in the hole I I
actually was gonna say something
you need to pick it up a little bit
Steph you really been struggling with
that the last 10 years yes exactly
talking about putting the ball in the
hole we were